THOSE WILL BE TWO SIGNIFICANT
INDICATORS AT HOME.
>> Tucker: WE WILL BE LOOKING
FOR THAT.
BILL, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
SO ONCE THE CORONAVIRUS PASSES,
AND AT SOME POINT, IT WILL PASS.
WE CAN’T DO THAT.
THERE IS TOO MUCH TO FIX AND WE
JUST LEARNED THAT.
THIS DISASTER ARRIVED HERE FOR A
NUMBER OF REASONS, SOME OF THEM
WE COULD NOT CONTROL.
PANDEMICS ARE INEVITABLE.
WE SHOULD ACCEPT THAT.
BUT OUR RESPONSES TO THEM ARE
NOT INEVITABLE.
NOBODY FORCED US TO OUTSOURCE
THE PRODUCTION OF THE CENTRAL
MEDICAL SUPPLIES TO CHINA.
OUR LEADERS DID THAT AND THEY
DID IT ON PURPOSE PAIRED THEY
DON’T TO TALK ABOUT A NOMINAL
BUT THEY DID IT AND IT WAS A CRI
THE COUNTRIES WELL ENOUGH TO
FUNCTION NORMALLY ARE GOING TO
HAVE TO CHANGE THAT IMMEDIATELY
FOR OUR OWN SAKE AND FOR THE
SAKE OF HER CHILDREN.
WE NEED TO HAVE ESSENTIAL
MANUFACTURING BACK TO THE
UNITED STATES.
MORE BROADLY, WE NEED TO START
TREATING CHINA LIKE THE
DANGEROUS COLD WAR ADVERSARY IT
HAS CLEARLY BECOME.
DON’T LET THEM LIE TO YOU.
THIS CRISIS BEGAN IN CHINA.
EITHER WAY, CHON’S THIRD WORLD
HAS PLAYED A CENTRAL ROLE.
CHINESE OFFICIALS SILENCED
HEALTH OFFICIALS WHO TRIED TO
WARN THE PUBLIC.
TODAY, BEIJING ANNOUNCED IT IS
REVOKING THE PRESS CREDENTIALS
FROM THE BIGGEST AMERICAN
NEWSPAPERS.
THEY DON’T WANT US TO SEE WHAT
THEY ARE DOING THERE.
AT THE SAME TIME, THEY ARE
THREATENING US.
ONE STATE BACKED MEDIA EXPLAINED
THAT CHINA MAY CUT OFF OUR
SUPPLY TO PHARMACEUTICALS.
CHINA IS AN EMINENT THREAT TO
THE UNITED STATES.
ONE OF THE UPSIDES IS THAT WE
CAN NOW SEE THAT CLEARLY BECAUSE
IT IS CLEAR.
BUT SOME OF US CAN’T SEE IT.
AMAZINGLY, THE RULING CLASS IS
TAKING THE CHINESE SIDE.
THAT AGAIN IS THE GOOD NEWS
ABOUT A CRISIS.
IT CLARIFIES THINGS.
YOU CAN SEE EXACTLY WHAT SIDE
PEOPLE ARE ON.
NOW, SOME OF OUR LEADERS DO THIS
ON PURPOSE BECAUSE THEY ARE
GETTING RICH FROM CHINA.
MANY ARE JUST TOO DUMB TO KNOW
THE DIFFERENCE.
DUMBNESS IS ALMOST ALWAYS THE
EXPLANATION.
CHINA UNDERSTANDS HOW TO CONTROL
THEIR EMOTIONS AND THEREFORE
THEIR MINDS.
THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT KNOWS
THAT IDENTITY POLITICS IS THE
GREATEST WEAKNESS IN THE
AMERICAN SYSTEM.
IT ALWAYS IS THE GREATEST
WEAKNESS IN EVERY COUNTRY.
THAT’S WHY THEY DON’T ALLOW
IDENTITY POLITICS IN CHINA.
THE CHINESE KNOW THAT ANY DEBATE
IN THIS COUNTRY CAN BE DERAILED
INSTANTLY IF SOMEONE SCREAMS
"RACIST."
SO, THE CHINESE HAVE DECIDED TO
USE "
"
WAUKOMIS" AGAINST US.
THE
MOST THIS IS A COUNTRY THAT
STANDS OUT TIBETAN CULTURE.
THEYTHIS COUNTRY IS CALLING US
BIGOTS.
IT’S HILARIOUS IN A WAY.
WHAT IS AMAZING IS HOW MANY IN
OUR MEDIA TAKE IT VERY SERIOUSLY
SERIOUSLY.
THEY TWEETED "RACISM IS NOT THE
RIGHT COOL TO COVER YOUR OWN
INCOMPETENCE.
"IN EUROPE, CHINA ACTUALLY
PROMOTED THE SPREAD OF THE
CORONAVIRUS.
IN EARLY FEBRUARY OF THIS YEAR,
THE CHINA TELEVISION NETWORK
RELEASED THAT THEY HUG --
THE VIDEO FEATURED A YOUNG
CHINESE MAN WEARING A FACE MASK
HUGS FROM PASSERSBY.
MORE RECENTLY, THE SAME CHINESE
NETWORK TWEETED THIS QUOTE.
"SHALL WE CALL H1N1 AMERICAN
FLU?"
NO.
WE WOULD RATHER FOCUS ON SAVING
LIVES.
IT BEGAN IN MEXICO, NOT THE
UNITED STATES PAIRED MEANWHILE,
CHINESE AMBASSADORS ARE
SPREADING THE RUMOR THAT IT
ORIGINALLYORIGINATED HERE IN AME
DON’T BE SHOCKED IF AT LEAST ONE
MEDIA OUTLET PROMOTES THAT IDEA.
DAVID FROM OF THE ATLANTIC
SUGGESTED CALLING IT "THE TRUMP
PLAGUE" INSTEAD OF THE VIRUS.
TODAYTHEY SAID IT WAS BOTH INACC
AND HARMFUL.
ANOTHER STATEMENT WRITTEN IN OUR
NEWS MEDIA.
THE PRESIDENT, TO HIS CREDIT,
DOES NOT SEEM INTIMIDATED.
>> OTHERS HAVE CRITICIZED YOU
FOR USING THE PHRASE, "CHINESE
VIRUS."
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT THAT?
>> CHINA WAS PUTTING OUT
INFORMATION WHICH WAS FALSE THAT
OUR MILITARY GAVE.
THAT IS FALSE.
RATHER THAN HAVING AN ARGUMENT,
I SAID, I HAVE TO CALL IT WHERE
IT CAME FROM.
IT DID COME FROM CHINA.
I DON’T THINK SO.
I THINK SAYING THAT OUR MILITARY
GAVE IT TO THEM CREATES A STIGMA
STIGMA.
>> GOOD FOR HIM.
THAT WAS TRUMP AT HIS VERY BEST.
WHY WOULD OUR MEDIA TAKE THE
SIDE OF CHINA IN A CRISIS LIKE
THIS?
WELL, BECAUSE INSTEAD OF TRYING
TO CONFRONT CHINA AND FREE
OURSELVES FROM THEIR CONTROL,
OUR PROFESSIONAL CLASSES
DEFENDING THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT
AND STORING UP PROPAGANDA.
WHY?
IT IS ACTUALLY WORSE THAN THAT.
IN MANY WAYS, YOU CAN’T BLAME
THE CHINESE FOR THIS.
THEY ARE DOING WHAT ANY
GOVERNMENT SHOULD BE DOING.
THEY ARE PUTTING THEIR COUNTRY
AND ITS INTERESTS FIRST.
NO, CHINA DOMINATES AMERICA
BECAUSE OUR OWN LEADERS SOLD US
OUT.
THEY DIDN’T KNOW WHAT THEY WERE
DOING, BUT EVEN WORSE, THEY WERE
GREEDY.
THEY WERE LOOKING FOR SHORT-TERM
BENEFITS FOR THEMSELVES RATHER
THAN LONG-TERM SECURITY FOR OUR
COUNTRY.
SOME OF THEM SEEM TO GENUINELY
DESPISE AMERICA, PARTICULARLY IN
ACADEMIA.
THAT’S WHAT HOLLYWOOD DOES EVERY
DAY OF THE YEAR.
SOMEDAY, THESE PEOPLE MAY BE
PUNISHED FOR WHAT THEY’VE DONE.
AGAIN, IT’S A CRIME.
AT MINIMUM, THEY WILL HAVE TO --
FOR NOW, WE DON’T HAVE TIME FOR
THAT.
WE NEED TO BE HONEST ABOUT WHAT